"It's a little bit of a big day for me
because I happen to have three members
of the Class of 2018 that share the same last name."
Meet the Bowden triplets: Lauren, Stephanie, and Alison.
The girls' dad, Dr. Scott Bowden runs the Emory Orthopaedics and Spine Center.
Now his three oldest daughters are going into the family business. "The Bowden triplets are gonna be all
three going into orthopaedics and they all matched at excellent programs and they're ecstatic."
"It runs in our bones, apparently."  [All three laugh.]
"Yeah, it makes it even more special that all three of us were able to match at the same time and
kind of go through this whole process together."
The girls have done a lot together over the years.
Combined, they weighed less than 10
pounds when they were born, but the
struggles they faced as infants were soon overshadowed by their later successes.
As teens they were all-star athletes and graduated with the highest GPAs in their high school
The three went on to Pomona College
in Claremont, California,
and are now members of the 2018 Emory University School of Medicine graduating class.
"Today, at least for the three of us, it's huge.
It's basically a culmination of everything we've been working for for the last 3 1/2 - 4 years"
Since retiring as an internal medicine physician, the girls' proud mom, Dr. Mary Caulfield Bowden,
has kept busy with the couple's five children.
She says the triplets are anxious to blaze their own trails, even though it means
they will have to live in separate cities for the first time in their lives.
"They're ready. You know, they kind of tried to go their separate ways in college,
but they all kind of like the same program, you know at Pomona,
and then same thing here at Emory. They just really all kind of gravitated to this school.
And then they kind of all agreed that this was a time to kind of be their own person
and spread their own wings. It'll be good for them."
"It's been amazing. And so we're finally parting ways.
Bittersweet, but I think we're all ready for it."
"It's been a lot of fun. I mean it's kind of like one step at a time.
We've always been there to  help each other out. We've had good friends,  good, kind of teachers and role models and mentors.
And we've always been prepared for the next step."
"It's exciting that we're all going to be going through similar experiences at different locations.
So I think we'll all stay very close. I mean, we're a very tight-knit
family, if you haven't noticed."
"This is something they know has been coming,
and I think they're looking forward to it and absolutely ready for it.